not interested no thank you
Oh
Oh what is this five-year-old threatens
to dethrone YouTube King very bad over
my goddamn dead body over my vegan how
could this be
Jefferson gray ham huh okay alright
Jefferson grayham five-year-old strains
maybe this kid got what it takes
Who am I the next PewDiePie let's say
let's check out some content
[Music]
brush your teeth Brian Higgins going in
to take a bag got a tricycle
mr. Rhyne toyomi oh [ __ ] I don't have an
intro [ __ ] let's make one right now
welcome to Felix toy will go has it
really gun to that point making fun of
five-year-olds watch some of the videos
and they'll remind you of the videos you
make that's what I want to watch I mean
why would I watch what I made when I can
just watch other people make the same
[ __ ] that really could have had really
certifies oh [ __ ] oh my god I just
became one of those that says why would
you watch someone else play video games
when he play it YouTube's biggest star
as a five-year-old that makes way the
Verge's well what the [ __ ] is happening
are we talking about the same diverged
The Verge that will take any opportunity
they can to [ __ ] on me oh okay that's
interesting
Peter Patrick and others took money from
war the butters for positive game rivas
a straight-up lie that I debunked [ __ ]
you for the last 18 weeks counting my
intro reviews has been the most popular
channel on YouTube the youngest our
YouTube is a ever seen is that are we
celebrating this are we celebrating that
the fact that some this mother is like
you think he's getting any money of this
do you think he's getting the toys I
also really like how they link every
video ever
in their description I really appreciate
that the genre skyrocketed once kids
became the hosts the kids are not the
hosts okay let's watch a video and I'll
show you what I mean yeah I don't know
who will you catch see she doesn't even
let him finish
he was clearly about to say something
there who will you look at him you know
you don't matter cuz I matter you shut
the [ __ ] that Brian
you can sue the noises inside yeah oh my
god I think he I think he came up with
that sentence himself and no one else
told him to say that I don't like I'm
sure he loves it you know I'm sure I
would love when I was a kid to open a
bunch of toys but at the same time it's
like it's something awful about it it's
kind of like seeing child stars on
television because you know like their
parents are literally forcing them to do
it and it's just something sad Abidin I
I can't help but get this aim vibe you
know obviously I don't know what goes on
but I I watch it and I'm like
increasingly it feels like Ryan is
reading from a script' know the script
being my mother saying hey you [ __ ]
say this YouTube stars of driving retail
sales I can't argue with that
subliminal advertising at its finest
sponsored episodes yeah
it's clearly they're sponsored by
Walmart it's 100 percent it's so clear
like watch this video where they're like
we got a exclusive Walmart neg and we
even found a Walmart exclusive version -
ooh why would any kid give a [ __ ] about
that explain that to me okay why would
any kid give a [ __ ] about Walmart
edition it doesn't make any sense and
then you get you get the verge posting
they took money for Warner Brothers
positive game reviews even though he
didn't talk about inadequate disclosure
huh okay well where is it here Ryan's
success in other words translates into
more money for his parents Oh for a
larger corporation okay okay all right
so basically there's a legal loophole
but that there's no way for it for the
antics of any ordinary Chuck kid to be
commercialized many states have no rules
around children performing then they
have no child labor laws around
performance but channel isn't just Ryan
playing with toys anymore where he's
going to Disneyland getting a haircut or
running a fever his parents are the ones
deciding how much you see what I'm
getting at here have you ever seen a
video with 11 million views and
thousand likes please direct me to that
video because it doesn't exist these are
not real people these are not real views
there's only a thousand comments take a
video where I had 11 million views
I got 22,000 comments 22,000 1000 most
viewed video has 600 million views what
the [ __ ] what the app excuse me what the
actual [ __ ] what the [ __ ] that's more
than half then call me maybe
or you say like everyone in the entire
[ __ ] world you know who this kid is
I bet you most of you who've seen this
video to have no [ __ ] clue how do you
get that amount abuse how can the verge
and you would say today fail to realize
this how can they run such a full cover
like this and not mention it you know
I'm not here to criticize this family I
don't care I genuinely don't care like
do whatever you want don't get me wrong
this is not the point the point that I
want to make which I am absolutely
[ __ ] stunned that no one that these
two big big journalists website the
verge and you would say today like with
the [ __ ] look at this look at this
it's the [ __ ] feature let's see maybe
is bought mentioned anywhere no fake
views no this whole article no way so
congrats you pay you you paid for views
and that's how you get the title oh he's
beating booty pot and I think that's
what pisses me off so much because
people want to [ __ ] tear me down all
the [ __ ] time how can you call
yourself a journalist and get it this
[ __ ] wrong how can you read that
[ __ ] [ __ ] all you had to do will
scroll the [ __ ] down
you're so stupid
I [ __ ] hate the media it's [ __ ]
embarrassing
welcome to felix toy will go okay baby
felix can you do it again huh but more
energy okay
mommy needs some dollar my name energy
mommy needs dollars okay um can you do
it again baby but can you do it with
more energy more energy yeah hey here's
a rip bowl okay mommy needs some dollars
so you need to look happy that's it the
whole thing there you go - Cole I can't
do it again but happy oh good
hahaha Furby is my new favorite toy okay
mommy's got you a Furby yeah yeah yeah
aren't you excited yeah okay oh my god
don't go in the box
I don't me got to return it I don't get
don't get to keep it no mommy needs new
nails okay open it there's a knife from
my eight-year-old son here we go wow wow
oh it's so cute this is camera it's so
it's so cute more energy
ah oh my mommy it's pink
I won't blue ah this one has mask or
when it's sleeping it's sleeping now
isn't it great
if
mommy wants you to burn him
mommy I don't want air it's my friend
kill your friend but it's my friend it's
mister first of all the only way you can
become a man is if you kill what you
love that what happened today
whoa
okay what did you think of your new toy
why did you kill him did you have fun
with your new toy was my only friend we
were supposed to leave this town he was
everything to me we were supposed to go
with her mountains meet the ocean and
the desert meets the sky I loved him I
loved him with all my heart and you made
me kill him you see the hot knife
challenge you seeing the hot name how he
cuts through anything I've been living
off the grid for 30 minutes I survived
thanks to mr. Percival's knowledge but
after 31 minutes I don't change -
everything changed
[Music]
I hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did check out another one it's right
here and it's also about similar topic I
think you might if you enjoyed this one
you might enjoy this one as well that's
great
keep watching thanks for watching
also remember to hit the bell ringing I
need to buy like a bell or some [ __ ]
that'd be cool